[Music]
sharks
we thought we'd uncovered the many
mysteries these creatures of the deep
have to offer
we were wrong yes that is your hand
very good we're all gonna die the norway
is a descendant of an ancient
shark god he has very kind eyes those
not me he's developed the taste for
human meat
no no no would you eat your friends no
you are a little idiot hungry on hbo max
august 6th pretty darn
super villains
[Music]
sad souls and costumes wanting you to
think they're all
dark and deep what's the like
living life is a punchline
[Music]
but all it would take would be one
blessed act of rebellion
for you to restore your dignity in its
entirety
you know the deal complete the mission
you get 10 years off your sentence
you fail to follow my orders in any way
and i detonate the explosive device in
the base of your skull
love him or hate him these are your
brothers and sisters for the next few
days
any questions and yes that is your hand
very good we're all gonna die
i hope so oh for god's sake
[Music]
this is suicide oh that's kind of our
thing
[Music]
not like a bloodbath to start the day
they call you peacemaker
i cherish peace with all my heart i
don't care how many men women and
children i need to kill to get it
i thought you was a crazy one oh yeah
here's the deal we fail the mission you
die we find out any information you give
us is false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you die what no
[Music]
foreign